YOSSI ELKRIEF: We can't
hear you guys.
No?
Is it just me, or anyone
else can hear them?
WEIBE ELSINGA: No, I can't
hear them either.
MALE SPEAKER: And I too
couldn't hear him.
Now it's OK.
RICHARD HYMAN: OK.
We just thought we might
even be toast.
We can see the little bars going
red every time I talk.
OK, well, welcome to this
week's Android Developer
Office Hours.
It turns out there's a mute
button on our microphone, and
I just pushed it while trying
to get the microphone out of
shot to reveal the lovely pink
Android car here, instead.
It's not really an
Android car.
It's just an Android
driving it.
I'm Richard Hyman, and
I'm joined today by--
CHRIS BAINES: Chris Baines.
RICHARD HYMAN: Developer
programs engineer.
Thanks, all, for joining.
As normal, this will be an
Android developer discussion.
We won't be making any product
announcements, talking about
roadmaps, that sort of thing,
so please don't ask.
We have a moderator that we'll
be taking questions from, and
also the comment stream
for the Google+ post.
Welcome to everyone who's joined
us in the Hangout.
A few familiar faces again,
thank you all, joining.
If you want to say hi, we've
got Yossi there, hey Yossi.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Hi, guys.
RICHARD HYMAN: Wiebe, from
Holland, next to him there.
WEIBE ELSINGA: Hi.
RICHARD HYMAN: One of the
founders of the Dutch Android
User Group, as his lower
third is saying.
[? Leonid, ?]
I believe, works with Yossi?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, a
new one [INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD HYMAN: First
timer on our show?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah,
first time.
RICHARD HYMAN: Etienne, hi
there, good to see you again.
ETIENNE LAWLOR: Hey,
how's it going?
RICHARD HYMAN: Really
good, thanks.
Having a good week.
Is that Ali on the end there?
Hi there.
ALI DERBANE: Hello.
RICHARD HYMAN: Good
to see you.
We were just discussing before
we went live, not so much
happening in the Android
world this week.
After CES finished last week,
we've had quite a quiet week.
CHRIS BAINES: Yeah,
a long January.
RICHARD HYMAN: Yeah,
slow January.
Nick's not with us today, so
we've been joined by this
Android who drives his own car
around, believe it or not.
Android left.
Android right.
We have a whole fleet of these
things now, they race around
the office and scare people.
CHRIS BAINES: Especially when
we drive them around the
office on a Friday afternoon.
RICHARD HYMAN: Friday
afternoon, after
a few beers, yeah.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: It's
using the ADK to
move, or is it a simple--
RICHARD HYMAN: I don't know,
I tried asking him, but he
wasn't very vocal.
What do you do?
No, it's using a remote control
system, but also it's
got pedals and steering wheels
and stuff, you can drive it.
WEIBE ELSINGA: Old school.
RICHARD HYMAN: Old
school, yeah.
So this is our Nick Butcher for
the week, if you have any
questions for Nick.
CHRIS BAINES: It looks
quite similar, too.
RICHARD HYMAN: Yeah.
Hey, Andrew, nice to
see you again.
I saw the one-man moderator
machine put plenty of
questions in the moderator
for us this week again.
OK, so let's kick off.
Does anybody in the Hangout have
anything they'd like to
talk about, or any questions?
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah, I would
like to raise a question about
using the ProGuard.
I've run into some issues.
After we added some loaders to
the simple application we're
trying to do as a POC
first of all.
We're using loaders, and
basically we wanted to do
ProGuard on the loaders also.
And every time we use the
loader, even though I'm using
the keep class with members
classifier for ProGuard, I
still get a verify error
for the specific class.
Did anyone ever get
this error?
I didn't see anything on Stack
Overflow related to it, so I
wanted to know if anyone was
able to use loaders fully,
which fragments and action
bar and everything.
RICHARD HYMAN: In ProGuard.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah,
in ProGuard.
CHRIS BAINES: In the
Support [? Lip ?]
Lotus, or native--
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah,
support ones.
CHRIS BAINES: And you're
getting a verify error?
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah, I get
Java-lang verify error.
CHRIS BAINES: Hm, I
never saw that.
RICHARD HYMAN: Caught us off
guard with that question
straightaway.
It's funny, because we
do recommend using
ProGuard, of course.
It reduces the footprint of
your application, makes it
more efficient, and can
do some great stuff.
There was a really good talk
from Eric, the man behind
ProGuard, at DroidCon
UK this year.
You can look it up
and watch it.
He did give some hints and
tips during that talk.
Have you had a look at the
ProGuard video from Eric?
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah, I did.
And basically I just wanted
to make sure if you ever
encounter something like that.
Because what I found and
what [? Leonid ?]
also found that some problems
with using fragments, based on
the Action Bar Sherlock and
loaders, and obfuscation.
But no one actually gave us
something to work with, only
just assign issue, and
it was resolved.
RICHARD HYMAN: Interesting.
The only thing I can say is to
not using the classes, and try
implement--
I can't remember what
the callback is.
Input the callback on your
fragment or activity.
Instead, ProGuard shouldn't
retouch it, as long as you set
an exception for the method.
So I'd try and do that instead,
and see if you still
get a verify error.
You shouldn't really,
but without
looking more at details--
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah, I can't
expose all the code.
Because basically, it's
something we're trying to
build as a new feature
on our app.
It's difficult to put
them all together.
RICHARD HYMAN: Does anyone else
in the Hangout have any
thoughts on ProGuard--
well, this sweet use
case for ProGuard?
You could raise the question
or issue over at
tools.android.com.
The ProGuard integration is
managed by [INAUDIBLE]
team over there.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: I'll try over
there also, and I'll try to
post it again on
Stack Overflow.
CHRIS BAINES: Yeah, ping me a
link to the Stack Overflow.
[INAUDIBLE]
Because Hugo said have
you tried it without
optimizations turned on?
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah,
optimization turned off,
turned on, including libraries,
keep optimization
on the public folders,
you name it.
RICHARD HYMAN: OK, sorry
we can't be of more
help on that one.
I haven't ProGuard-ed
too much.
Not too much point,
because I'm a
projects for open source.
Any other questions from inside
the Hangout, before we
jump to the moderator?
ETIENNE LAWLOR: I had
a quick question.
I was wondering about
two native apps--
the Phone app, and
the People app.
So both the Phone app and the
People app have two list views
that load lists of contacts.
And it looks like the
People app does
something similar to--
there's an Android training
that does loading bitmaps
efficiently.
And I think you guys actually
gave a demo.
I think it's called Bitmap Fun,
and it handles loading
bitmaps efficiently.
And it looks like the
People app does
something along those lines.
But the Phone app, if you look
at the list of contacts,
there's some list that the
bitmaps seem to be cached, or
they've already been
stored in cache.
And any time you leave the Phone
app and go back in, it's
not like it re-tries to
grab those bitmaps.
Is it doing something
different?
RICHARD HYMAN: Yeah,
it probably is.
The Phone app is a
high priority.
I'm guessing it's always running
to actually answer the
phone calls.
So maybe it's just keeping
this list in memory.
CHRIS BAINES: The source is
available, so you can always
have a look through.
RICHARD HYMAN: Yeah, it's
probably caching them anyway.
Even if you reboot your phone
and have a look, are they all
there as soon as it opens up?
So this app's starting up from
boot, caching all the photos
that it needs to and,
just staying there.
ETIENNE LAWLOR: Oh, as soon as
the phone is booted, it's one
of the priority things.
CHRIS BAINES: Yeah, I imagine
that's the case.
I've never seen the Phone
app not be running.
I'll see if you can see it
inside all the running apps.
ETIENNE LAWLOR: Because it grabs
all of the names and the
numbers, without any hiccups,
or scrolling.
Everything is completely
cached.
CHRIS BAINES: I doubt the name
and number is, I doubt that's
just doing a content
provider query.
But probably at startup.
ETIENNE LAWLOR: I mean, I know
loading the bitmap is the
expensive operation.
CHRIS BAINES: It depends where
you're loading it from.
All the images on the
contacts will be on
local storage somewhere.
ETIENNE LAWLOR: Yeah,
local storage.
It's not from the network.
CHRIS BAINES: Exactly.
So it would be quicker anyway,
it will load in milliseconds
rather than seconds.
ETIENNE LAWLOR: Most of them
are, but there could be some
linked with your social
accounts.
CHRIS BAINES: Even the social
accounts, they still have to
put it into the content provider
and the contact
content provider saves
the files.
And so it never was local.
RICHARD HYMAN: Actually,
I've got them to load.
So it is starting on startup.
If you go into Settings,
you can find one called
Phone/Messaging storage.
And you can force-close it.
If you force close Phone and
Phone Messaging Storage, and
then go back and load the
application, you can see all
the icons start to load again.
So it's launching on startup.
It does request the boot up
startup permission launch.
It looks like it's starting on
startup and doing the exact
same thing to cache
the data at that
point, and staying resident.
ETIENNE LAWLOR: If I'm trying to
display some lists similar
to that, from a design
perspective, do you think it's
a big hindrance to have to load
those images each time
without saving it to cache,
to some kind of
hard cache every time?
RICHARD HYMAN: To actually call
them out of the contact
content provider?
ETIENNE LAWLOR: Basically what
I'm doing is clearing the
cache each time the
app is killed.
RICHARD HYMAN: The problem is if
you don't do that, and then
someone changes the contact
photo, you're not going to
pick it up, are you?
So it's a good idea to do what
you're doing, and then reload
them from the content
provider.
ETIENNE LAWLOR: OK.
So just because it's not loading
at the same speed of
the Phone app doesn't mean it's
not doing it efficiently.
I'm doing it in a similar
way that the Bitmap Fun
demonstration does it.
RICHARD HYMAN: I would
say that's fine.
They are cached on the disc, and
you're just loading them
through the content
provider anyway.
So re-caching them a second time
on the disk isn't going
to help too much.
CHRIS BAINES: It's the same
storage, so it's not going to
make a difference.
In fact, you'll be probably
saving to SD
card, or external storage.
Whereas the contacts provider
that's saved on the false
directory, your data storage
which, depending on the phone,
might be the same storage, it
might be slightly slower.
RICHARD HYMAN: Sounds
like you're doing
it perfectly, anyway.
I would stick with what
you're doing.
ETIENNE LAWLOR: OK.
Sounds good.
RICHARD HYMAN: Reduce the speed,
maybe you could cache
the first couple closer, but
I certainly wouldn't
cache the full list.
ETIENNE LAWLOR: OK.
RICHARD HYMAN: All right.
Anyone else from inside the
Hangout have a question?
Sorry, I'm just looking at the
chat window over there.
[? Beaver ?] and Andrew Kelly
have just posted some things.
MALE SPEAKER: I have some
question about the AsyncTasks.
I have some problems with the
method of doing background,
not invoke when [INAUDIBLE]
the task execute.
So I found some post, that
when you work with SDK,
Honeycomb and above, you need to
do execute on the executor,
and not on execute.
So the question of why would
you do it that way?
RICHARD HYMAN: There was a very
good explanation of this
is a talk at DroidCon
Holland this year.
Wiebe, did the DroidCon
talks go live?
WEIBE ELSINGA: No, not yet.
RICHARD HYMAN: Just wait until
those talks go online, because
there was a change in the way
that AsyncTask does work
through Gingerbread,
Honeycomb, and
then Ice Cream Sandwich.
And if I remember it correctly
Gingerbread was--
CHRIS BAINES: [INAUDIBLE] tasks
from what I remember.
And then on Honeycomb, it
changed so there's only one
thread running at a time.
RICHARD HYMAN: Because that's
what we saw the multicore
processors coming in, and apps
were getting responses to
AsyncTasks back in an order
they weren't expecting.
So we have it single-threaded to
make those apps work again.
But then, Ice Cream Sandwich,
we defaulted back to
multi-threaded again, unless you
specify single-threaded.
Either way you can specify, and
the best thing to do is
definitely to specify an
executor, and say whether you
want it to be single-threaded
execution of all the
AsyncTasks or multi-threaded
execution.
MALE SPEAKER: So the only
problem is in the Honeycomb?
RICHARD HYMAN: I think there
was another case as well.
CHRIS BAINES: It's changed
quite a lot.
I'd look at the Java Dock.
It should tell you
the differences.
I'm just looking now.
MALE SPEAKER: Can you post some
link to that explanation?
CHRIS BAINES: Yes, I will.
RICHARD HYMAN: We're just
looking at the AsyncTask Java
documents like the
Android developer
documents at the moment.
But it has been on
Stack Overflow a
number of times as well.
So the thing to do is definitely
to specify an
executor anyway.
We definitely recommend that.
And you can guarantee
with either your
ThreadPoolExecutor, or your
executor, whether you want it
to be single-threaded or
multi-threaded across all of
the versions of the OS.
MALE SPEAKER: OK, thank you.
RICHARD HYMAN: In Hugo's
place, [INAUDIBLE]
has joined instead.
Hey, there.
And John has joined with
a picture of a laptop.
Let's actually grab a question
out of the moderator, then.
ALI DERBANE: I also got
a question still.
I gave a presentation
about expansion
files on DroidCon Amsterdam.
It was pretty cool.
I gave it after first having
played with it, and now there
is a customer, and he wants
an updated application.
But he wants to keep using the
expansion files that we
uploaded for the previous
version of the application.
I updated the stuff that needed
to be fixed, and now I
just want to test if the new
application works with the old
expansion files, or
the previously
uploaded expansion files.
When I try to do that on my
Samsung Galaxy S-- which is a
pretty ancient phone,
I guess--
I do get the message saying that
the expansion files were
downloaded, even though when I
browse to the file browser,
and look at the location where
the expansion files should be,
there is no expansion
file at all.
Have you got any tips on that?
Do you know where
I should look?
RICHARD HYMAN: I would
definitely re-upload the
expansion files when
you change the APK.
ALI DERBANE: Always re-upload?
RICHARD HYMAN: I can check with
the publisher's site team
here, but I've heard some
inconsistencies before, and
it's just a good idea to
re-upload the expansion files.
We've had it before that APKs
have been uploaded, and then
the expansion files weren't
being downloaded, because they
weren't associated
with that APK.
ALI DERBANE: OK.
So I should just try and upload
it again, and see if
that works?
RICHARD HYMAN: Yeah, you may
be downloading an empty
expansion file, if there's
nothing assigned to that APK.
And then that's why you're just
seeing a blank space on
the SD card.
ALI DERBANE: OK.
I will check that out.
RICHARD HYMAN: If
you could try it
during the next 20 minutes--
oh, no it will take two
hours to go live.
ALI DERBANE: It will
take awhile.
Well, thanks.
I'll give that a shot.
RICHARD HYMAN: Ping us on
Google+, because I'd like to
know the result, just to check
that that did fix the problem.
ALI DERBANE: Thanks very much.
MALE SPEAKER: I have
a question.
RICHARD HYMAN: Oh, who's that?
Hey, there.
MALE SPEAKER: Hello?
RICHARD HYMAN: We can
hear you fine.
MALE SPEAKER: I'm a beginner
in programming in
college here in Egypt.
We study the C Sharp.
But I really like programming
apps for Java, for Android.
And I want you to give
me some advice.
Do you have to be a professional
[INAUDIBLE].
I can build very good
Android apps.
RICHARD HYMAN: Sorry, I missed
one word out of that.
Do I have to get something to
build very good Android apps?
MALE SPEAKER: Do I have
to be a pro at Java?
RICHARD HYMAN: Do I have to be
a Java pro to build good
Android apps?
It definitely helps.
If you know your Java design
patterns and you know how the
Java models work, it can help
make better Android
applications, but you can
definitely start off with
simple Android applications
without too much
knowledge of Java.
All the UI layer of Android is
done without any standard Java
in it, really.
MALE SPEAKER: More of the
websites, or the videos that I
can do, they can give
me a good start.
RICHARD HYMAN: Yeah, I wish Nick
was here, instead of this
pink car with a green Android
in it, because he was a .net
developer [INAUDIBLE]
at some point, and switched
over to Java/Android.
So he may have been able
to help with a
migration path for you.
MALE SPEAKER: Thanks.
RICHARD HYMAN: I would, because
I like to just get
stuck into things, I would just
start coding Android, and
get used to it.
And then if you come across
problems, assume that they've
already been solved by someone
else, and look
them up on the internet.
If you want to figure out how to
do a certain design pattern
in Java, just look it up.
Sometimes it's slightly
different for Android anyway,
because of the way
activities work.
MALE SPEAKER: Thanks
for the advice.
RICHARD HYMAN: No problem,
thanks for
joining us in the Hangout.
CHRIS BAINES: Andrew Kelly's
put a question.
RICHARD HYMAN: Andrew
Kelly's put a
question in the chat window.
CHRIS BAINES: If I have an
IntentService as the interface
to a REST service, what is
the best way to have the
IntentService pop up and
progress dialogue on the UI
while the REST call
is executing.
Do I need to use a broadcast
receiver?
RICHARD HYMAN: I don't like
getting feedback from
IntentService myself.
CHRIS BAINES: I always think
of IntentService
as a one-shot deal.
RICHARD HYMAN: [INAUDIBLE]
CHRIS BAINES: Yeah, exactly.
It's not something you want
feedback off, or a callback,
or anything like that.
So the way I'd personally do
that is do a normal service,
and then run your background
query on a
background for an executor.
And use a handler to make sure
a dialogue, which feels hacky
from a service, but you want a
different activity, really.
RICHARD HYMAN: If you have an
activity that's bound to the
service, you can request
the progress.
[? Google Aid ?]
2010 gave a talk on using
IntentService from [INAUDIBLE]
REST.
But as [? clients ?] for REST.
That's fine, but then showing
the activity on the screen--
did it cover that during the
presentation, Andrew?
Andrew is typing.
CHRIS BAINES: The only way I
think that could work nicely,
is if that IntentService
is updated
from the content provider.
And your activities
[INAUDIBLE]
getting re-queried when the
content provider changes.
That's the only nice way
I could think of using
IntentService, that
kind of stuff.
RICHARD HYMAN: This is another
good case for that AsyncTask
talk that was given at
DroidCon Holland.
It actually covered of all types
of background processing
on Android, and when
to use each one.
It was an amazing talk.
So as soon as that goes live,
I think I'll just make sure
everybody watches it.
CHRIS BAINES: The slides
are online.
I've read the slides.
WEIBE ELSINGA: I don't think
the talks will be
going online soon.
RICHARD HYMAN: Fair enough.
He did put the slides online,
I seem to remember
slides did go out.
So we could look up the name of
the guy who gave the talk.
Do you think you could
find it, Wiebe?
WEIBE ELSINGA: I'm looking
right now.
RICHARD HYMAN: If we find the
guy who gave the talk, we can
find the slides and
just post them in.
It would answer two
of the questions
here in a lot of detail.
WEIBE ELSINGA: Give
me five minutes.
I'm no good at multitasking.
RICHARD HYMAN: Execute
a thread.
Thread executor.
No, just executor.
Wiebe's brain.
He's not using a
ThreadPoolExecutor.
That's what I was looking for.
I would have been a more
funny joke if I could
actually say it.
OK.
I'm just going to have a quick
look in the G+ comments.
CHRIS BAINES: So, while
Richard's looking, Pavel's put
a question on the moderator
asking, with data storage, the
SQL API haven't evolved
since Android 1.0.
Is there any chance we'll
see alternatives--
something that's similar
to the core API in iOS?
There's nothing planned from
what I know, and what's
available at the moment.
All I can do is point you to
libraries that build upon it.
So you've got greenDAO, which
works pretty well.
You've got ORMLite, and
there are other paid
solutions as well.
So just look at them,
[INAUDIBLE].
The DAO Solutions can not
perform with penalties, but
they're usually worth it.
[INAUDIBLE]
code from your--
that you don't have to
write basically.
So it's always good.
So have a look at them and
let us know Anyone
else got any questions?
Take that as a no.
RICHARD HYMAN: I'll be
back in one second.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Everybody's
doing searches on there.
CHRIS BAINES: You OK?
Is there anything on Google+?
RICHARD HYMAN: On Google+?
Not really.
Someone was asking how
to join the Hangout,
which was just answered.
And then they've got a question
which they'll ask if
they can join the Hangout.
So if Jackie does get in, she
can ask the question live.
If not, I'll wait five minutes
before answering that
question, just in case
CHRIS BAINES: Michael has put
a question on the moderator,
asking, I heard about an app
that claims it is able to back
up data from other apps, and
will be able to restore it on
the device.
I thought this isn't possible
without root access.
What are your thoughts
on that?
RICHARD HYMAN: I thought
it was impossible.
Well, if it's on the SD card.
CHRIS BAINES: Yeah, that's
the only way
it could work, really.
RICHARD HYMAN: It might
be reading the data
directory off the SD.
Hey, Jackie, there you are.
You found the link.
Good to have you in as well.
CHRIS BAINES: Because the data
directory for each app has the
permission set so only the
application can access them.
So I don't really see
how that's working.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Unless they're
using shared intents and
shared permissions.
CHRIS BAINES: But you'd have to
share with every app that
could be installed
in the world.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: No, I mean if you
have a set of applications
from the same software vendor,
they're using the same
certificate and the
same permissions.
So they have shared permissions
to back up all the
data, and to access all the data
between all their apps.
CHRIS BAINES: Yeah, but
only for their apps.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Besides that,
each app has a private
location for their storage.
Only if they used the SD
card to save all their
preferences and stuff.
But even then, I think the new
the user's API will block the
access to the SD card.
And basically, we get a virtual
mapping for the SD
card for each user.
So I don't think an app for
backup will be helpful on
those devices.
RICHARD HYMAN: I'm trying to
find the question in the
moderator to see who asked it.
Oh, it's Wiebe.
We can't ask Wiebe to
multitask even more.
WEIBE ELSINGA: No, Ali already
asked the question.
RICHARD HYMAN: The one about the
app that can do backups?
WEIBE ELSINGA: No, about
the extension files.
RICHARD HYMAN: OK.
You had that one as well.
But who asked the question
about the backup apps?
I thought it was
Wiebe as well.
Where is it?
I'm on the wrong day here.
It's the 16th, right?
We've got a lot of devices,
we have to use them all.
CHRIS BAINES: Oh, Michael.
Michael [? Panza ?].
RICHARD HYMAN: Michael Panza--
I heard about an app that claims
it would be able to
back up data.
The app is called Carbon.
He did put the app name in.
Let me check it out
on my [INAUDIBLE].
I couldn't find it.
CHRIS BAINES: All right.
Jackie, do you have
your question?
MALE SPEAKER: Can you hear
me, first of all?
RICHARD HYMAN: Yeah,
absolutely.
MALE SPEAKER: So I'm working
a lot on trying to do some
porting of some native
applications, and it's kind of
something I'm new to.
And I'm having some difficulty
getting Make to work right
with the standalone
tool chain.
Have you guys had any experience
with that?
I've read through the
documentation a little bit for
the standalone tool chain.
There's some environmental
variables
it talks about setting.
But I was just curious--
it's hard to tell if it's
working or not until you go
through and check out the
objects that get created.
But do you guys know, is there
a good resource for
this type of thing?
It mentions in the documentation
that the
standalone tool chain was made
specifically so that you could
use Make, but I don't see much
documentation on how to
implement it with Make.
CHRIS BAINES: Personally,
I have no idea.
Because I've never done
C++ [INAUDIBLE].
I'd recommend posting your on
question Stack Overflow,
because that's all the
native questions.
I'd go on there, really.
That's probably where you're
going to get it most exposed,
and probably answered.
RICHARD HYMAN: You can have a
look at tools.android.com
again, and have a look at the
documentation that's over there.
Have a look at the forum at
tools.android.com as well.
Post a question in there, maybe,
because then one of the
Tools Team here will take
a look at it at least,
especially if you're
got a specific
error that you're seeing.
MALE SPEAKER: OK, sounds good.
It was more just a generic
question on getting Make to
work with the standalone
tool chain.
I'm not very good with Make, so
I'm trying to figure that
out on my own.
CHRIS BAINES: The only other
time I have built something
with the NDK is when
I used the command
NDK-build rather than Make.
And that calls Make
itself, I think.
So have a look at using
that, maybe.
MALE SPEAKER: I'm using Make
because I'm trying to port
over existing C libraries.
Basically, I'm working on
tutorials to be able to use
Box 2D, and OpenGL ES, and C,
and then use JNI hookups to
communicate with it.
And so I'm trying to rebuild
Box2D just on my own, and I'm
having some problems getting
it to build with the Make
scripts that come with it.
CHRIS BAINES: I think NDK-build
actually calls Make itself.
I can't remember the
exact details.
But you create a special Make
file, and you can then include
other Make files from it.
So you may need to do some
of that, but include
your custom Make file.
I don't really know, though.
It's pulling the depth
of my memory, here.
MALE SPEAKER: I just
figured I'd ask.
Thank you, though.
RICHARD HYMAN: Cheers.
And whilst you were answering or
asking that, Wiebe did post
the DroidCon NL presentation
in the chat window here.
WIEBE ELSINGA: I hope this
is the good one.
RICHARD HYMAN: Is it on tasks?
I'm going to see if I can just
quickly cross-post it into the
[INAUDIBLE].
WIEBE ELSINGA: It's about
Android threading.
CHRIS BAINES: That's the one.
RICHARD HYMAN: Just bear
with me a second.
I can't find my own Hangout
now that I'm actually in.
This is crazy.
If you could cross-post that
onto the Hangout comments,
Wiebe, that would
be really handy.
WIEBE ELSINGA: I already did.
RICHARD HYMAN: Excellent,
thanks very much.
So anybody who has questions
about AsyncTasks and
background services-- there were
two of them so far-- it's
definitely worth checking
that presentation out.
OK.
Do we have any other questions
inside the Google+ thread?
We've had 11 comments now.
OK.
[INAUDIBLE]
Michel Panzer put the link to
that app that claims to be
able to do backups.
CHRIS BAINES: Hmm,
interesting.
RICHARD HYMAN: Let's
see what it says.
It's from Kuish, for a start,
from ClockWorkMod.
Sync apps and app data between
phones, back up apps to your
SD card, Google Drive
or Dropbox.
Check the video out.
It requires Android 4+, this is
a Beta, this requires root.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: It says
the final version
doesn't require root.
I'm watching the video
right now.
RICHARD HYMAN: [INAUDIBLE]
Android or just ClockWorkMod?
YOSSI ELKRIEF: No, I think
maybe it's based on the
ClockWorkMod, or maybe it's
using the device administrator
features for Android 4.0.
And basically, then you can
access everything you want on
the device.
Because I didn't see the
permissions when installed it
or something.
RICHARD HYMAN: Yeah, there's
definitely something going on.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: As you can see,
super user on the video.
Oh, he's using the
full restore--
RICHARD HYMAN: ADB backup
and restore.
He's using a command-line shell
through ADB for non-root.
So it's not actually
running it on the
device at that point.
Which isn't a bad thing.
ADB Backup and Restore
is very, very
powerful, and very handy.
And I use it all the time for
keeping my game state data
when I re-flash my phone,
which happens more
than it should do.
Most users would never think
about doing that.
Even developers are unlikely
to plug it into a computer
USB, ADB backup.
Because you can actually
securely back up all your
data, your SD card and
everything through that, and
then restore all your
app data again.
So if someone's writing an
application which uses the
functionality of ADB Backup and
Restore, but makes it more
user-friendly, then that's
kind of awesome.
It is allowed, it's not
breaking any of
the security codes.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: No, he's using
Google Drive to basically save
your data as a backup file, and
then you can log in on a
different device and have the
data back from the Google
Drive to your device.
RICHARD HYMAN: At the moment,
you run a shell script to get
it working, by plugging it in.
So whether he's going to manage
to side-load something
onto the device, which means
he can do those backups
without it being plugged
into a computer.
If he could, that would
be awesome.
I'll read through the
rest of the thread.
CHRIS BAINES: I didn't think
there was an ADB
client on the phone.
RICHARD HYMAN: There isn't.
You can't do the ADB backup on
the phone at the moment.
CHRIS BAINES: [INAUDIBLE]
RICHARD HYMAN: I don't
know what he's doing.
When the final version comes
out, I will definitely try it.
Because there's plenty of games
that I use that I'd love
to have the game data
synchronized
between all my devices.
Even if I had to just quickly
run this application to
restore my latest, or back up
my latest data, or even have
it scheduled to do that,
it would be cool.
Go Kuish.
What's appeared in
the chat window?
CHRIS BAINES: It's [INAUDIBLE]
question, which I first saw on
the moderator.
I think we're better to add an
animation progress method into
animation lists so that more
operations can be performed
when an animation is running.
A question while you're
trying to know why an
animation is going.
Surely when you start the
animation, you'll know that
it's started.
So I'm not sure why you want
to know how far into the
animation it is.
Because you won't really to be
changing the view midway
through an animation.
Because you're just causing
more work for the GPU.
I question why you
want to know.
RICHARD HYMAN: You know when it
starts and when it's ended.
And how long it's
going to take.
CHRIS BAINES: Yeah, because
you call that.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: He's
writing again.
I'll show the screen in just
a second to show you.
RICHARD HYMAN: That's the screen
you see when you type
ADB backup.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: That's
what I'm saying.
That's why the user is
[? seeking ?] to backup each
and every application.
Then the data is being uploaded
to the Google Drive
account for the specific user.
RICHARD HYMAN: Sorry, Yossi,
that is Carbon, but it's a
video of Carbon, right--
that you're showing
at the moment?
You're not running it on your
device at the moment, right?
YOSSI ELKRIEF: No.
RICHARD HYMAN: I just wanted
to know whether it's doing
that without needing
to be plugged in.
There's a review of it over at
Android Central as well.
It was posted on Monday.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Basically, when I
look on the notification bar
on the top, I don't
see the device is
connected to anything.
RICHARD HYMAN: It still says,
even from Monday, the Beta
still require root access.
The final version should
be non-rooted, but no
one's seen it yet.
So watch that space, I guess.
CHRIS BAINES: [? Jay ?]
has put a reply on.
"I need to update light params
during animation progress
[? and using ?] to handle
that is more code.
Changing the light params
during animation--
I'm not too sure on that one.
I question why you're
doing that.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Why should you do
that during your animation?
Unless you want to change
objects on your animation
while it's running.
CHRIS BAINES: If you need to
change the light params during
an animation, I would use a
handler and do it that way,
using the post.
And then keep posting
yourself.
RICHARD HYMAN: If you're going
to have an on-progress update
listener, it's going to be using
a handler to send those
updates back to the
UI thread anyway.
So whether you use a handler, or
we have a method that uses
a handler, it's going
to be the same.
Fair enough, there's an extra
five lines of code that you
need, but it shouldn't
be a problem.
CHRIS BAINES: [? Michelle ?]
from Denmark?
Sorry if I butchered
your name there.
"It was a reported that the
[? replies for ?] review
option was being rolled
out to more developers
about a week ago.
I'd really like an official word
on this, as it's a much
needed feature.
RICHARD HYMAN: Yeah, it is a
much needed feature and it is
still being tested.
So I think it was quite public
that the initial test group
was the top developers.
It's not being rolled out at
the moment to everybody.
Hopefully it will be at some
point, if the tests go well,
and the feature is used as the
team are expecting it to be
used and all that
sort of thing.
We may be able to announce
more at some point.
It's certainly [INAUDIBLE]
to all developers.
It's hitting their accounts
right now.
That's a great feature.
CHRIS BAINES: That's it
in terms of questions.
I think we've answered all 17.
RICHARD HYMAN: All
17 questions.
Excellent.
And there's nothing else
appearing in the Hangout chat.
WIEBE ELSINGA: I know a
co-worker just posted a
question on the Google+
comments.
RICHARD HYMAN: Let me
just refresh it and
see what comes up.
I've got a quick question
from Jefferson Poe about
AppWidgetProvider.onupdate.
The docs say that AppWidget
IDs may include all the
AppWidget instances
or just a subset.
What's the criteria of
which instances are
included in the array?
Have a look at the source.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: It depends on if
you added the widget, and
then removed it, or if you tried
to add more than one
widget on the same screen.
RICHARD HYMAN: But then you
would expect all of the
AppWidgets that are currently
on the screen to be called
when an update calls, right?
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yes.
Basically what I do on our
widget is go through all the
array all the time, no matter
how many instances, and check.
And update them all.
Or you can lock the feature for
more than one widget on
screen, and see if you have
another instance running of
the AppWidget.
And then, just pop up the
dialogue to the user, saying,
you can't have more than one
widget running on the screen.
RICHARD HYMAN: The question
is implying that the
documentation says it may not
bring up all widget IDs of all
the current active widgets,
it may be a subset.
And maybe that would happen.
It's worth checking
the source.
There is rate-limiting about how
often widgets can update.
If you've updated one recently,
forced an update to
it, then maybe it won't request
the [? auto-update ?]
during its cycle.
I don't know that for sure.
You'd have to check the code.
All it's saying is that you're
not guaranteed to get the
entire list of currently
active widgets.
Like you'll see, I always just
go through the list that I've
got, unless you have other
ones that need updating.
Hugo says, "I have a layer-list
drawable, and I
want to add a line to the
bottom of the drawable.
The drawable is going
to be scaled.
I can't get the line to be
at the bottom half of the
drawable, only in the center.
Any tips?" Ah, layer-list
drawables.
They're not very well
documented, are they?
CHRIS BAINES: No, they're not.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: So Chris, start
writing the Java Docs.
RICHARD HYMAN: There
you go, yeah.
CHRIS BAINES: Cheers, Yossi.
WIEBE ELSINGA: Your
next code snippet.
RICHARD HYMAN: I'd have to
knock up the layer-list
drawable and play around
with it myself.
Maybe you could put a shape
inside the drawable that's the
size of the entire drawable but
only has a bottom margin
or something.
CHRIS BAINES: There
is no line shape.
There's a shape, but you
can't layer it on.
I think the only way you can
do a drawable is probably
putting a rectangle in over
[? a tag on top, ?] from what
I remember.
So I don't know.
We'll have to have a look
at that one offline.
And see what we can
[INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD HYMAN: See what
we can hack together.
WIEBE ELSINGA: A
code challenge.
RICHARD HYMAN: Yeah,
sounds quite fun.
I always just play with those
ones, until it looks like I
want it to look like.
I have used them a few times.
Dustin Evans, at the very bottom
of the G+ thread has
asked for, "I was wondering if
anyone has any guides on Oauth
tutorials for Android
development.
I've pretty much done the Hello
World tutorials, and
would like to dive deeper."
Yeah, we have two.
If you look at Google Tasks,
and then go for the code
samples for Google Tasks,
there's an Android code sample
that does include Oauth.
I've used that a few times.
We did a Google Drive code
lab that used Oauth.
You can look for that.
We gave it at Devoxx
this year.
In your Google Play services
authentication as well, if
that can cover your needs, then
that's definitely the
best way of doing it now,
because you can just
authenticate against
the Google account.
So have a look.
But the most commonly used
Oauth example is the
Google Tasks one.
So check out Google Tasks.
I'll see if I can
grab it quickly.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: But
it's quite old.
And all of the Play services
were not using the Oauth
methods for now, because we're
getting the Tokens.
Developers.googl
e.com/google-app
s/tasks/oauth-an
d-tasks-on-android
RICHARD HYMAN: That sounds
probably like it.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: I'll post
it also on the G+.
RICHARD HYMAN: You can see the
Android sample there, can you?
You've got it.
CHRIS BAINES: Yeah,
he's [INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD HYMAN: Excellent.
Yeah, try that.
That was where I first
figured it out.
CHRIS BAINES: Andrew Kelly has
put a comment saying how to
moderate a question
on fragments.
That's the one I answered
earlier.
RICHARD HYMAN: Andrew didn't
join in for the first few
minutes, so did we answer it
before Andrew joined us?
CHRIS BAINES: No, I answered
it offline, so we can go
through it again if
I can find it.
RICHARD HYMAN: Stay with us as
we re-moderate the question.
CHRIS BAINES: Andrew Kelly
had a scenario
where he replaces fragments.
So he adds a fragment via XML.
And then throughout his
activity, he replaces them
with other fragment.
And what he was finding was that
the first fragment, which
is out of your XML, it wasn't
being replaced.
It wasn't actually
being removed.
It was still stuck there behind
all the fragments.
So he wasn't getting the onPause
or onDetach for you,
or [INAUDIBLE].
And so he was asking why
does this happen.
And to answer you,
I don't know the
reason why it happens.
But I put a solution available,
where he replaces
the XML fragment tag
with a [INAUDIBLE].
And actually adds the first
fragment in his onCreate.
So that way it will all keep
happening as before.
I haven't looked at
the source yet.
Yeah.
"Unnamed" is me.
RICHARD HYMAN: Why is that?
CHRIS BAINES: I don't know.
So yeah, that's the only
solution I can think of.
I haven't looked at
the source yet.
I'm going to have a
look after this.
Of the reasons why, my guess is
that the view group, which
is out of your XML, is needed,
so it can't be replaced within
the activity.
But that's my guess without
actually looking.
Etienne said it works,
so sounds good.
I don't think there's
any other questions.
RICHARD HYMAN: Yeah,
we have one.
I remember seeing it,
it's something about
share action provider.
"I would like to have a
custom share provider.
It looks like activity data
model hinders me quite a lot
in doing this.
Any advice on doing it more
easily?" Have some custom
share provider.
And then later on, "What is
ActionProvider onPrepare
sub-menu used for?" Maybe you
could put those questions in
the moderator for next week.
I might take a look at them
during the week, and answer
them formally for you,
[? Jens ?], if you
can wait that long.
CHRIS BAINES: I think
we're good.
RICHARD HYMAN: Yeah.
Thank you all very much for
joining us, I think we'll cut
it short there.
We're only 10 minutes
early, aren't we?
Not too bad.
WIEBE ELSINGA: Time to
drive the Android!
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
RICHARD HYMAN: I think he's
having trouble with his
three-point turn.
That way.
He's gone.
There you go.
WIEBE ELSINGA: Android
is dead.
RICHARD HYMAN: Cheers, guys.
CHRIS BAINES: Bye, guys.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]